PROFESSOR: Scattering states are
energy eigenstates that cannot
be normalized.
And when you say this
cannot be normalized,
so what's the use of them?
They don't represent particles.
Well, it's like
they e to the ipx
over h bar, those
infinite plane waves.
Each one by itself
cannot be normalized,
but you can conserve wave
packets that are normalized.
So the whole intuition that
you get with scattering states
is based on the idea that
we're going to construct
energy eigenstates.
This time we cannot think of
them as states of a particle.
Bound states, yes.
We can think of them,
they're normalizable.
But this energy eigenstates
and bounded scattering states
are not states of one particle.
So we definitely have to go
back and produce wave packets.
But the intuition from
those energy eigenstates
is very valuable.
So scattering states.
And we call them sometimes
scattering states
because they look like
the process of scattering.
This will be non-normalizable
energy eigenstates.
And you've played a
little with some of them.
And we'll now study
one case in detail.
We'll try a couple of cases
between today and next lecture.
So the step potential.
And the step potential
is a potential
that is 0 up to x equals 0.
Here's the x-axis, and then
suddenly there's a step at v0.
And here is the potential.
But then the wave,
this is here, goes up.
It's a step.
And any energy eigenstates
here has to be bigger.
The energy has to be
bigger than the lowest
point of the potential.
You know that, you kind
of have an energy that
is like that less
because this would
have decayed exponentially
for infinite distance.
It just, all over it would
have to decay exponentially.
It's impossible.
So all the energy
states, eigenstates here,
must have positive energy.
So we have actually
qualitatively
two possibilities.
The energy may be less than
v0, might be greater than v0.
It would look like you have to
solve the problem two times.
Happily, we'll solve one,
then let the other happen
by analytic continuation.
So here is the energy.
I'll take the energy
greater than v0.
But whatever is the energy,
even if it's less than v0,
the solution over
here is going to be
an exponential or a cosine and
a sine, a non-decaying function,
and therefore can't be
normalized because it's
non-decaying forever and ever.
So it cannot be normalized.
So how do we write the solution
for the energy eigenstate?
It's a psi of x.
Well, I should write two
formulas: a formula for what's
happening on the left side,
and the formula for what's
happening on the right side.
Now I have a choice
actually here.
There's two ways of
visualizing this.
I can visualize it as a wave
that is coming from the left,
moving here.
Or a wave that is
coming from the right.
So let's visualize this
solution as a wave that's
coming from the left.
It will be a little easier.
So I will write it.
A e to the ikx.
OK.
Why is it coming from the left?
Because if you put the energy--
that I will not put it,
it's in stationary state,
presumably this is a state
with some fixed energy.
You will have a factor e to
the minus iEt over h bar.
And when you see
kx minus Et, you
know that that's a wave
that is moving to the right.
So this A e to the ikx
is moving to the right.
And then what will happen?
Now it's a matter of
finding a solution
of Schrodinger's equation.
So you can try to find the
solution of Schrodinger
equation, but you have to
write some answers for what's
happening on the right.
I will write an answer
here, that we'll
put C e to the i k bar x.
And another k.
Well, we'll see now
what those k's are.
I say the following.
Here, the energy is
bigger than the potential
so it has to be a wave.
But here they energy is still
bigger than the potential
so it also must be a wave.
But a wave with
different kinetic energy,
different momentum, therefore
different de Broglie
wavelength and different k.
But we know from Schrodinger's
equation what that should be.
This wave is also
moving to the right,
because probably if I have a
wave moving to the right here,
it produces some transmitted
wave to the right.
But then, you could try solving
the Schrodinger equation
with this.
It won't be enough
because physically you
would expect the wave bouncing
back as well from here.
So I will put a B e
to that minus ikx.
That's a wave moving
towards the left
with an unknown coefficient.
And, now let's get
those constants.
I'll finish in two minutes.
What is k?
Well if you have energy E,
you know that the energy is h
squared k squared over 2 m.
You can look at the
Schrodinger equation
with 0 potential over there.
And therefore, k squared
is also 2mE over h squared.
It's a combination you've
been seeing quite a bit.
The intuition for
k bar should be
that k bar squared is 2m
times the kinetic energy,
so it should be e minus
v0 over h squared.
So these are k and k bar.
And the wave function must
be continuous at x equals 0.
That gives you A plus B equal
to C. At 0, all the exponentials
vanish.
And the derivative must be
continuous at x equals 0.
And the derivative being
continuous because there's
no delta function anywhere here.
So you have ikA, that's the
derivative of the first term,
minus ikB, the same k in
that region of course,
is equal to i k
bar C. So from this
you get A minus B is
equal to k bar over kC.
Two equations and two unknowns.
And that's OK, even though
there are three coefficients,
because the way to think
of this is that you're
sending in some wave
and you're going
to get some reflection
and some transmission.
So in some sense,
A is the input.
You could want to
call it 1 or whatever.
So what we're looking
for is what is B over A?
And what is C over A?
And these two equations,
it's a one line computation.
I'll write the answer.
B over A is k minus k
bar over k plus k bar.
Do it for fun.
And C over A is 2k
over k plus k bar.
B gives you a sense of
how much is reflected.
C, how much is transmitted.
But this is the beginning.
Because this is not
a particle coming in.
So we'll have to
build the packet
and send it in and see
how this relations tell
you what's going to happen.
So this is a nice story that
we will develop next time.